bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver hors de vous
retrouver sur public sénat c'est
toujours excitant je ne vous le cache
pas de démarrer une nouvelle émission
j'ai le bonheur de vous donner
rendez-vous tous les jours pour 90
minutes de débat d'actualité de
réflexion sens public sens public tout
est dans le titre en fait notre promesse
et de donner du sens à l'actualité et de
nous mettre au service du public nous
voulons donner des clés de compréhension
aux citoyens en cette année
présidentielle le scrutin majeur de nos
institutions celui qui structurent
l'histoire de la vème république depuis
plus de 60 ans vous allez pouvoir juger
sur pièce parce que c'est bien beau de
dire on va donner du sens au service du
public vous allez pouvoir juger sur
pièce pendant toute cette saison et déjà
avec le premier sommaire de ce premier
sens public mercredi c'est la fin d'un
ultimatum pour 2 millions 700 mille
soignants celles et ceux qui refusent de
se faire vacciner s'expose à des
sanctions le gouvernement peut-il les
appliquer sans déstabiliser le système
hospitalier ce sera notre débats d'actu
les électeurs ont la parole les
électeurs ont la parole c'est une
rubrique qu'on vous proposera tous les
jours dans ce sens public et pour
commencer le coup de gueule d'un
contribuable contre la hausse de la taxe
sur les ordures ménagères ça peut monter
en tout cas selon les témoignages
jusqu'à 40 % dans certaines villes et
vous verrez c'est intéressant parce que
derrière cette situation il ya tout un
débat autour de la vitesse de la
transition écologique marine le pen
est-elle has been la question va faire
hurler j'en suis convaincu ses plus
fidèles soutiens mais alors de la
poussée et mourra leur de l'unc houdré
dans le rétroviseur ses résultats
électoraux
plutôt décevant lors des élections
intermédiaires nous ne sommes pas les
seuls à nous poser cette question
l'avenir de la candidate du
rassemblement national cela ce sera le
thème de notre débat prospectif tout à
l'heure
mais d'abord donc mais d'abord les
réfractaires ils ont prévu de manifester
demain à l'appel de la cgt santé les
anti vaccins des hôpitaux des ehpad des
casernes de pompiers ces médecins ces
infirmiers ces aides soignants qui
refusent de se faire vacciner
malgré l'ultimatum de l'exécutif et le
risque de sanctions c'est un sujet de
cécile siksou
comme cette psychologue hospitalière ils
sont plusieurs soignants à avoir
symboliquement rendu leur blues lors des
manifestations passées ni terre ce
week-end à paris à partir de mercredi
ces réfractaires à la vaccination seront
sanctionnés la loi prévoit de les
suspendre de leur travail sans
rémunération s'ils n'ont pas reçu une
première dose de vaccin
aujourd'hui il représente près de 12%
des employés des hôpitaux et des ehpad
et 6% des soignants libéraux
la sénatrice et ancienne infirmière
christine bonfanti-dossat espère que la
mesure fera bouger les derniers
réticents j'ai l'impression que cette
obligation
va entraîner des prises de conscience et
que la semaine prochaine on aura déjà un
nombre suffisamment optimale qui va nous
faire dire que la partie est
pratiquement gagnée car à partir du 16
octobre fini la tolérance les soignants
devront être entièrement vacciner faute
de quoi leur contrat de travail sera
suspendu et le gouvernement a prévenu il
fera des contrôles en cas d'arrêt
maladie des sanctions trop lourde pour
le sénateur eric bocquet il faut
absolument éviter la contrainte c'est
par un état de droit c'est inimaginable
on ne peut pas accepter d'être suspendu
lancé droit et de plats sans salaire
pour cette raison il faut
c'est l opposition d'anglais le
développer la vaccination tous azimuts
mais par la conviction et par là contre
les syndicats craignent de leur côté que
ces sanctions entraînent des pénuries
dans certains services hospitaliers
ils appellent à manifester demain contre
l'obligation vaccinale
effectivement risque pour une
catastrophe sanitaire comme le prédit le
secrétaire général de la cgt philippe
martinez quelles sanctions pour ces
réfractaires comment expliquer ce refus
du vaccin par ceux qui justement ont
notre santé entre les mains pour en
débattre jacques et sabrina kemmel
bonjour un pusher bienvenue vous êtes
avocate spécialiste du droit du travail
associée au cabinet ftms gilbert de ré
bonjour un jour bienvenue chef du
service néphrologie à la pitié
salpêtrière et publié plusieurs tribunes
une dans le jdd l'été et puis une
dernière dans l'express avec ce titre
les anti vaccins révélateur d'une
société malade de son égoïsme et de son
inculture j'accueille également romain
gizolme bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de l'association des
directeurs au service des personnes
âgées les ehpad et les soins à domicile
si j'ai une seule j'ai résumé évidemment
la question des réfractaires elle se
pose concrètement dans vos
établissements à vous aussi et puis
chatel matthieu croissandeau dont je
viens du l'éditorialiste tous les jours
dans cette émission d'ora j'aurai à mes
côtés un ou une éditorialiste matthieu
croissandeau le
lundi et le mercredi et lætitia cru pas
les mardis et jeudis merci mathieu je
suis très heureux de démarrer cette
aventure avec vous alors je vous propose
peut-être et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
pas si facile d'y répondre d essayer
d'avoir des chiffres pour commencer
selon le dernier bilan de santé publique
france 88 % des soignants avaient reçu
au moins une dose dans les hôpitaux et
les les ehpad
94% des soignants libéraux
90% ça fait 12 % qu'ils n'ont pas fait
environ 300000 personnes qui
manqueraient à l'appel qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ses collègues gilberto
est ce que est ce que vous essayez de
les convaincre vous quotidiennement dans
votre service pas de mentionner c'est
pas la peine c'est 100% de vacciner okc
tout va bien vous êtes enfin quant à moi
tout ce qui m'entoure ça fait quand même
18 mois qu'on parle de la copie gérer
plus de six mois qu'on parle des vaccins
je vis ça fait un moment que le
gouvernement
a mis les cdat il apprend d'ailleurs que
ce cette hésitation vaccinale et les
quoi les un ou deux pourcent de
totalement réfractaires c'est pas un
problème juste d'information les
informations ya des tonnes en a même
trop et donc on est on est plus dans ce
débat-là les vaccins sont sûrs les
vaccins sont extraordinairement efficace
on va quand même rappeler que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
il protège contre tous les campings
delta des formes graves à plus de 90%
donc ça nous aussi on est à plus de 10%
dans les hôpitaux qui ne l'ont pas
encore fait leur choix parce que ils
prennent leur temps parce qu'ils sont
pas forcément anti vaccin il ya
plusieurs choses la première c'est que
je pense qu disparu de l'inertie ici
avait pas eu ce café gouvernement et
quelques mois maintenant disant
attention au 15 septembre il va y avoir
des mets je pense qu'on en serait encore
à un taux de vaccination bat du cette
inertie et là on a encore un mois
attendons un peu les derniers chiffres
ma conviction c'est qu'il s'avère
beaucoup moins de 12% moi je vous a
ajouté qu'on n'a pas le choix de toute
façon parce que je suis patient
comprennent le sujet par le bon bout on
le prend si on le prend par le beau mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire s'il s'arrête
c'est pas ça le débat c'est quel autre
choix on a on en a pas on en a pas car
premièrement les soignants donne
l'exemple des soignants qui se vaccinent
pas ça drôle d'exemple quand même pour
le reste de la population je vous dis
renvoyer je suis d'accord
c'est la première chose c'est la
deuxième chose c'est que il se met en
danger parce que lorsqu'on est soignant
le risque de l'attraper l'aco vide est
beaucoup plus important que la
population générale le risque d'être
hospitalisé pour une forme grave est
multiplié par sept le risque de décès
est nettement augmenté et ça vaut non
seulement pour ceux qui sont en première
ligne infirmières aides soignants
médecins mais ceux qui sont en deuxième
ligne dans les hôpitaux ils n'ont pas le
choix donc c'est aussi les protéger et
puis troisièmement et c'est sans doute
la raison majeure et c'est un problème
de notre société ça j'ai parlera mandat
lait contaminé un patient ou une famille
or depuis 18 mois la commune est devenue
la principale infections nosocomiales
dans les hôpitaux voire des comptes et
dans les dernières semaines alors que la
négociation est encore là on a plein de
témoignages de familles qui ont perdu
des proches parce qu un soignant les à
comptable est ce que c'est vrai aussi
dans les
et pas de romain gizolme pense que la
situation entre les hôpitaux et les
établissements personnes âgées sont de
différentes d'abord parce que c'est pas
tout à fait le même type de service dans
des services hospitaliers vous y passez
un temps vous en ressortez vous croisez
beaucoup de monde aussi les
professionnels sont amenés à croiser
plus de monde par exemple sur les
services d'urgence que ça ne peut être
le cas en établissement aux personnes
âgées les personnes âgées vivent sur ces
structures le personnel est plutôt
stable et le passage que vous pouvez
avoir c'est essentiellement des familles
quelques intervenants extérieurs etc la
situation n'est pas tout à fait la même
pour autant la question du bénéfice de
la vaccination et de la même manière
absolument évident on voit bien que
c'est depuis que cette campagne n'était
engagée notamment par ces professionnels
qui ont fait la réussite de la campagne
de vaccination auprès des personnes
âgées cette obligation vaccinale pour
les soignants comment ce qui arrive là
avec les sanctions etc comment vous
l'apercevez alors
d'abord on va attendre parce qu'on va
voir effectivement au 15 septembre quel
va être l'état de la situation
précisément moi je pense de l'anticiper
pardon d'aujourd'hui c'était difficile
six jours si vous avez des salariés dans
certaines dents soyez assurés
savoir pour savoir où ils en sont et
certains nous disent bien sûr et séance
là où je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord s'il faut se poser la question
de comment on va faire simple parce
qu'il est clair qu'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de nos adhérents disent
craindre un certain nombre de départs de
démission parce que là où l'obligation a
certes poussé à la vaccination pour une
part elle a aussi ready un certain
nombre d'indécis qui pas forcément anti
vaccin mais par contre très opposés à se
voir à me poser quelque chose et ça ça
va amener un certain nombre de personnes
très certainement a démissionné alors on
peut s'entendre est ce que ces 5 % est
ce que ces 10% on verra bien le cas j'ai
vu la tension qu'il en soit si ces deux
ou trois pour elle c'est exactement le
quoi qu'il en soit dans ses structures
pour personnes âgées où ils gagnent efi
cible de professionnels depuis des
années parce que la puissance publique
n'a jamais suffisamment investi quand
vous perdez 5 à 10% ça se constate et
puis au delà des chiffres et des
pourcentages qu'est ce que ça veut dire
dans la vraie vie c'est que si par
exemple j'ai en tête un adhérent qui me
dit sur ma structure j'ai deux
infirmières
j'en ai une qui ne veut pas se faire
vacciner et qui très certainement va
arrêter ses fonctions ça veut dire qu'il
m'en reste une infirmière et là c'est
pas du 5 ou 10% c'est de 10%
immédiatement donc j'entends bien qu'on
ne peut pas uniquement raisonner sur
comment on va faire sans pour autant
maintenant que l'état a décidé de cette
obligation il faut que l'état trouve
quand même quelques solutions pour voir
comment on va gérer cela parce qu'il y
aura nécessairement quelques départs
parce que nous il est clair que nous
n'accepterons pas d'être en mode dit
dégradé pour ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement quotidien des personnes
âgées sabrina kamel vaut vous vous
défendez
des salariés mais aussi des employeurs
dans ces dossiers est-ce que vous
ressentez un comment je peux dire ça un
peu de jusqu'au-boutisme cédé à certains
qui sont vraiment très aller au bras de
fer la suspension puis éventuellement
des sanctions plus lourdes alors oui je
défends principalement les employeurs et
enfin aujourd'hui non je ressens pas si
vous voulez de la part de mes clients la
volonté de sanctionner les salariés
parce qu'ils ne se serait pas fait
vacciner au contraire j'ai davantage
l'impression que les employeurs sont
dans une impasse parce qu'ils en fait
qui a plaisir à licencier des salariés
enfin hormis le cas de la faute et
cetera et cetera oui mais là on est dans
une situation bien particulière on veut
pas se séparer de ses salariés on veut
pas non plus payer des indemnités si on
doit les licenciés parce que ça coûte
quand même cher licenciement on en parle
peu du licenciement mais si vous voulez
on en parle peu pourquoi parce que la
loi nous parle de suspension aujourd'hui
tu contrat de travail mais derrière
cette suspension viendra forcément la
possibilité pour l'employeur de
licencier ses salariés puisque ne se
serait pas conformée à l'obligation
vaccinale il ya deux étapes ya
suspension d'un mois à six semaines pour
ceux qui n'ont reçu aucune dose au 15
septembre et ensuite 15 octobre
interdiction d'exercer interdiction
d'exercer oui mais donc qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait ses salariés
ni les employeurs voyez ne me dise pas
ben je le licencierait non pas du tout
en fait c'est comment on va s'organiser
déjà comment on va s'organiser en
interne parce que là je fais je vais
faire face à une pénurie alors dans
l'est dans les hôpitaux s'ils voulaient
de l'ap-hp peut-être pas mais je pense
aussi notamment aux dentistes aux
médecins libéraux moi j'ai pas mal de
dents de cabinet dentaire qui m'ont dit
pas que la majorité de leurs personnels
administratifs leur assistante ne
voulait pas se faire vacciner et donc
elle perdrait et bien sur un effectif de
7 4 personnes par exemple et donc elles
ne peuvent plus continuer à faire
tourner le le cabinet médical donc à
tous ces problèmes là qu'on va se
heurter effectivement je pense qu'il
faut essayer de trouver une solution
mais en l'état
avec la loi qui est passée la seule la
seule obligation aujourd'hui qu'ils
existent et celle de sur l'accident et
on est dans un état de droit je ne suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure par le monsieur
qui est passée qui était un manifestant
on reste dans un état de droit oui la
loi a été votée c'est vrai en urgence
mais après elle est passée par le
conseil constitutionnel
on reste dans un état de droit que l'on
le veuille ou non c'est quand même
important elle rappelé alors on va dans
un court instant à les entendre une une
responsable de la cgt que chu de
poitiers qui donc appel à manifester
demain mais gilbert devrait vous n'êtes
pas d'accord sur sur l'impact j'ai bien
compris vous êtes plutôt optimiste vous
dites finalement on a encore du temps
devant nous mais là on a deux
témoignages qui disent attention ça peut
quand même
créer un grain de sable un gros grain de
sable dans le fonctionnement d'un losc
en fait j'ai voulu remettre en premier
ce qui me semble être de toute façon une
évidence qui est qu' il allait falloir
fascination par contre je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur ce qu'il ya de tout la
pénurie elle existait avant et quelques
pour cent de moins c'est un problème il
ya des milliers de postes qui ne sont
pas pourvus en france dans toutes les
structures y compris l ap hp où je
travaille depuis des années on travaille
dans un flux tendu qui n'est pas
acceptable de la même façon qu'on a fait
un c ur l'année dernière pour
revaloriser assez pour réaliser les
salaires de se pose le même problème
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pas de soignants
dans les ehpad parle de soignants de
toute nature passe pas juste des
médecins ou même des infirmières une
auxiliaire dans une ehpad c'est aussi
important qu'un message du nepad
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
d'infirmière dans notre structure c'est
ce problème là qu'il faut mettre un dans
la cage vide comme beaucoup d'autres
choses c'est un révélateur sa révélateur
des inégalités c'est révélateur des
fractures et c'est un révélateur d'un
monde qui ne fonctionnait déjà pas donc
oui on va avoir des problèmes ce que je
crois c'est que on va être en difficulté
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on a
pas le choix on va être obligés passé au
travers et maintenant il va falloir que
certaines personnes dont des personnes
comme vous et au gouvernement également
et des directeurs d'hôpitaux 10 on fait
quoi maintenant pour pallier à ces
soignants qu'on n'aura pas mais on n'a
pas le choix alors deux éléments tout de
suite on va d'abord entendre des
infirmières qui manifestaient samedi à
paris il faut maintenant dans ce débat
donnait la parole à celles et ceux qui
refusent de se faire vacciner donc on va
d'abord entendre des infirmières qui
était à paris samedi et puis ensuite on
partira à poitiers écouter cette
réaction dans la manif samedi
mais vous vous rendez vous de ce que
c'est qu'un soignante a mis les
pieds dans la maltraitance
institutionnelle
et à qui on dit par an juste continuer
comme ça et je travaille signer 800
sujets vaccinés
asus tendu
mais quel pays démocratique
c'est juste j'ai travaillé avec hambourg
div
symptomatique je suis allée correct
contre
avec nous katherine girault qui
responsable de la communication à la cgt
au chu de poitiers avec nous en direct
en visioconférence depuis poitiers quand
vous entendez ces discours ensuite vous
on fera un point sur votre hôpital
combien de personnes ne sont toujours
pas vaccinées les difficultés que cela
peut provoquer mais je voulais que vous
entendiez ses réactions dans la manif et
puis on a beaucoup depuis des mois c'est
ces mots qui sont employées la
résistance les références à la seconde
guerre mondiale on est plus en
démocratie ça vous choque d'entendre ça
il ya des propos bien
qui soutenu par
choix je vais pas vous le cacher ce que
von
al-haq six nations et contre l'oubli est
passé et contrebasse est surtout les
conséquences qui ont cher
pardon de vous interrompre ça arrive les
visioconférences et les à la joie des
visio conférence depuis dix huit mois on
en a beaucoup écouté voilà on va
agresser ce petit souci matthieu
croissandeau
en entendant les uns et les autres ce
qui est intéressant c'est que finalement
on voit que le débat va assez vite
arrivés sur le politique sur la volonté
du politique d'aller au bout c'est à
dire on a voté une loi il faut
l'appliquer et comment on la pink quoi
et en même temps qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de l'état aujourd'hui j'ose il
a fixé la règle la règle doit être
respectée ont payé des policiers vexer
les gens il ya quelque chose aussi de
lors de la prise de conscience
collective et si jean-jacques veut pas
aller se faire vacciner on veut pas dire
c'est aller taffer rex mais jean-jacques
peut-être que ses collègues peut-être
que sa direction peut-être que sa
famille peut-être que ses voisins tout
le monde doit prendre conscience et tout
le monde doit essayer de convertir parce
que je trouve qu'on fait preuve d'une
très grande mansuétude vis-à-vis des
gens qui refusent de sahraj signer
aujourd'hui avec ce type d'argumentaire
non ils sont pas anti vaccins mais ils
sont contre l'anti l'obligation
vaccinale faut arrêter voilà aujourd'hui
il reste pas des gens qui sont anti
vaccins mais mai contre l'obligation
vaccinale vous soulignez tout à l'heure
il y avait quelque chose d'exemplaire
c'est comme un restaurateur qui rabat
non moi je mange pas chez moi parce que
ça me dit rien qui vaille c'est aberrant
on est dans une situation délirante donc
le politique confronté à ça et tu peux
plus il peut plus mettre un policier
derrière la faillite va pas mettre un
policier derrière des gens pour les
faire vacciner donc il ya quelques la
règle qui a été fixée moi je suis assez
de votre avis et bien je pense que plus
on approche de l'échéance plus quand
même la pression va être forte on l'a vu
sur le sur le reste il a suffi que
emmanuel macron le 12 juillet à dire 10
vous pouvez pu aller au bistrot au ciné
si vous n'avez pas si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné et alors que ça faisait des mois
qu'on répétait vaccinez vous pour
protéger vos proches vaccinez vous pour
protéger les plus faibles bal à tout le
monde il était donc dès qu'on fixe des
contingences comme ça très forte avec
des avec des seuils et des effets de
seuils et des dates limites
l'histoire de l'histoire montre qu'on
est là après il y aura sans doute une
fraction à mon avis assez minimales de
gens qui n'iront pas et c'est vrai que
ça posera un problème comment les
remplacer ça sera un problème que est-ce
qu'il faut les licencier ou pas comment
comment on fait mais j'ai on va pas
commencer à établir une règle générale
pour une fraction infime de la
population qui refuseraient de se faire
vacciner alors qu'on appelle quand même
les soignants sont soumis à un certain
nombre de vaccins obligatoires donc là
que vivent désormais mais je l'aurai
toute une série d'autres affaires vous
avez raison on peut ne pas être d'accord
ou pas d'accord avec la décision
politique est prise à un moment donné le
politique est là précisément pour fixer
un cadre donné des directions et prendre
des décisions c'est ce qu'a fait l'état
sur cette question là pour autant ça ne
peut pas se résumer qu'à ça c'est à dire
qu'on ne va pas effectivement prendre
des policiers pour aller vacciner les
personnes les personnes qui ne seraient
pas vaccinés aujourd'hui pour autant le
politique ne peut pas les laisser dans
la situation un certain nombre de
structures en disant écoutez la
situation on dessine qu'est celle ci est
ensuite les conséquences c'est à vous de
voir parce qu'aujourd'hui la situation
et celle ci
personne ne demande à revenir sur
l'obligation vaccinale
l'ad-pa elle même était pro vaccin je
lui le coup je tiens à ce que les choses
soient claires comme entendre comme
l'académie doit absolument le coma
bon nombre de personnes aujourd'hui
quand on voit l'efficacité de la
vaccination comme je l'évoquais en début
d'émission oui mais aujourd'hui on vous
sent marcher sur des oeufs à l'idée de
voir sanctionner des salariés non notre
notre inquiétude c'est que il est hors
de question que ce soit les personnes
âgées qui pâtissent d'une décision
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui mais il
faut plaider la situation mais je vous
donne un exemple la situation qui risque
de se produire certainement pas partout
parce que les situations soient un seuil
technique il ya des 100% de vacciner sur
certaines structures vous en avez au
moins sur d'autres dans les structures
où il va y avoir moins de professionnels
où il n'y a plus possibilité de faire
recours d'avoir recours à l'intérim
parce que les agences d'intérim
aujourd'hui non plus de vivier de
remplaçants
il est hors de question que ce soit les
directeurs ou les directrices qui
décident de ce qui ne sera pas fait en
termes d'accompagnement auprès des
personnes âgées vous avez un cas il ya
très peu de temps à montélimar me
semble-t-il ou à montbéliard est
précisément
l'établissement s'est vu déposé une
plainte parce qu'ils manquaient quatre
professionnels sur la structure et que
les soins n'étaient pas réaliser
correctement donc il est hors de
question que l'état s'en tiennent juste
à dire la règle et de celle ci et les
professionnels vont se débrouiller ça ce
n'est pas possible donc c'est en cela
que nous attendons du politique qu'une
fois qu'il a fixé sa décision il assume
aussi un certain nombre de conséquences
et qui pallie un certain nombre d'effets
collatéraux pervers selon comment on les
appelle alors cas d'école au chu de
poitiers on réessaie avec katherine
girault qui est donc responsable
communication cgt j'espère que le son
sera sera meilleur on va rentrer dans le
détail combien de
de personnel non vaccinées dans votre
pital est ce que vous avez pu l'évaluer
voilà quelques jours de l'ultimatum
bonsoir à tous oui on a alors les
chiffres donnés par notre direction
c'est que 80% des personnels ferai
vacciner au centre de vaccination du chu
de poitiers et les gains du tout dernier
chiche donnerait un état de 400
personnes dont on ne serait pas encore
en tout cas qu'il n'aurait pas fourni un
état de leurs vaccinations donc on sait
pas encore si l'onf ont vaincu les mets
qui ne l'ont pas fourni si ils ont quand
même l'intention de se faire vacciner
même au dernier moment ou si au
contraire ils donnent ils ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner donc ça pourrait
plusieurs centaines de personnes qu'est
ce qui va leur arriver à partir de
mercredi qu est-ce que vous anticipez ou
alors qu'ils leur arrivent déjà
malheureusement puisqu'on a déjà
accompagné des collègues dès cette
semaine là
qui
n'ayant pas fait de test
j'ai voulu expliquer pour quelle raison
se sont retrouvés à devoir aller
chercher un courrier de mise en demeure
et
qui devait présenter un tel sinon il
aurait été suspendu leur contrat de
travail alors c'est une collègue qui
revenait de vacances qu'il ya des
problèmes de saignements de nez et qui
du coup n'avait pas un fait les tests
qu'on met à disposition un hôpital
puisque son d'une tests pcr et elle ne
fallait pas qu'elle pouvait faire des
tests salivaires donc voilà la chose
c'est réglé comme ça mais va arriver le
couperet également mercredi de la
vaccination mais bon vous appeler à
manifester demain vous accompagnez
finalement les collègues qui vont
peut-être
voilà être sanctionné par par l'hôpital
mais est ce que votre rôle moi je vais
reprendre un peu les propos de de
gilbert de ré ou de même de mathieu
poissant d'ascq votre rôle c'est pas
aussi de faire de la pédagogie auprès de
ses collègues pour tout simplement les
convaincre de se faire vacciner
alors moi je considère pas que le soir
le rôle de la philippique faire fin
alors que nous on est un organe gâteau
familial
on a notre point de vue sur la
vaccination on est pour la vaccination
on est par contre contre l'obligation
vaccinale et surtout contre pas
sanitaires et surtout sur les sanctions
qui s'accommode de ces questions là mais
c'est pas notre rôle
d'éduquer ou sur la vaccination on peut
éventuellement discuter avec les
collègues donner notre point de vue mais
c'est pas nous de l'ailé du kiss et du
rhône bien sûr du gouvernement en
priorité mais moi je pense qu'on oublie
un acteur dans tout cela c'est le rôle
que devraient jouer les médecins du
travail dans nos établissements or la
médecine du travail aujourd'hui
actuellement été malmenés on a pu assez
de médecins du travail ils ne peuvent
plus jouer le rôle qui devrait jouer
c'est vraiment eux qui devrait te vas là
la personne de proximité pour conseiller
accompagner et du trou d'air de rêve
d'accord avec cette idée où vous dites
qu'un syndicat pourrait aussi jouer ce
rôle de pédagogue h accord avec deux
choses la première c'est que moments
terriblement de médecins du travail
c'est un désastre évidemment dans la
cage vide
l'état par an je voudrais souligner que
c'est encore pire pour la médecine
scolaire même si c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est dramatique et
alors par contre je suis en désaccord je
pense que nous sommes tous tous des
acteurs pour ce qui est de ceux de cette
histoire de vaccins et qu'une personne
comme vous en responsabilité qui qui qui
connaît le vaccin qui sait ce que ses
voisins avec les pros vaccin pourrait
être plus efficace que moi médecins sur
un plateau de télévision et on a très
très bien montrer que ce qui marche
c'est la personne qui la porte d'à côté
c'est vous c'est votre voisine c'est
votre voisin c'est votre père c'est
votre mère est donc j'aimerais au
contraire que vous soyez omniprésente
pour discuter des vaccins catherine
girod votre réponse
on est occupé à tout plein de choses et
on va être surtout aux côtés des
collègues qui vont se retrouver quand
même dans un monde de non-droit l'a
privé de contrat de travail et de
salaire donc voilà on a fort à faire je
vous dis pas qu au quotidien on en
discute pas et que de notre rôle est de
notre point de vue on oeuvre pas pour
cela mais on n'est pas le principal
acteur reconnaissait le et regardez par
exemple au chu de poitiers ce qu'on a
demandé nous c'est que le cadre de
proximité face ce rôle là alors ce rôle
d'éducation pourquoi pas sauf que les
cas de proximité elles sont surchargés
de travail avec en plus dans des
hôpitaux dans le dernier talent publique
ou dans les hôpitaux publics vous le
savez bien il y à un multitude équipe
multitude d'horaires de travail donc
elles ne peuvent pas toucher tous les
salariés voilà c'est quand même un vrai
problème c'est qu'on a je pense quand
même pas bien accompagner cette
communication cette éducation même qu'on
pourrait dire autour de la vaccination
que ce soit à l'hôpital où que ce soit
même dans le monde du travail ailleurs
on aurait pu avoir une système de
vaccination en proximité sur les lieux
de travail jeu ce qui n'a pas été chez
certainement par manque de personnel là
ce qui est grave c'est que pour nous
cette cette vaccination obligatoire qui
va imposer des sanctions elle va surtout
mettre en difficulté l'hôpital parce que
teddy 1 sur le plateau j'entendais juste
avant mon intervention que on est à flux
tendu en permanence on a de grandes
difficultés et là on peut pas se passer
même classique c'est bien un faible
pourcentage important de % à la liste
quand il aime le pourcentage de non
vaccinés et de personnes suspendues
sanctionné merci beaucoup katherine
girault de ce témoignage depuis le le ch
sud de poitiers sabrina kemmel
sait on est dans quel ordre d'idée c'est
à vous vous apprêtez à défendre combien
de dossiers d'après vous si vous essayez
d'anticiper je ne sais absolument pas je
ne le sais pas je pense pas qu'ils en
aient tant que ça très honnêtement mais
on n'est pas dans un monde de non droit
puisque j'ai entendu un endroit j'ai vu
que c'est un exotique oui qui m'a fait
tiquer parce que et c'est pas peu
importe d'être pour ou contre la
vaccination le cadre législatif est
posée aujourd'hui donc à partir de là il
ya des règles et ces règles il va
falloir les respecter donc on est bien
si vous voulez on est on est dans le
droit pour le coup la question c'est
comment tout cela va être appréciée par
les juges alors les juges alors là on va
être face à des conseils prud'homaux qui
vont appliquer la règle à la différence
en fait il faut il faut il faut faire la
différence avec vous savez les dernières
décisions qui est qui ont été rendues
par les tribunaux administratifs sur le
pass and it erp ou c'est complètement
différent je veux dire il n'ya pas s'il
est là on a vraiment un cadre législatif
qui est posé on a une obligation
vaccinale qui rentre dans le code de la
santé publique et à partir de là ce
qu'ils ne se feront pas vacciner
encourent des sanctions donc la question
elle est pour moi plus mais c'est ce
qu'on dit depuis le début de cette
émission elle est plus de comment on va
faire comment on va gérer et je pense je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
qu'au fur et à mesure en fait les
salariés quand ils vont se retrouver
bien sans salaire ce qui est quand même
ce qui permet de manger c'est
l'alimentaire mais c'est extrêmement
important de 2 le rappeler est bien vont
être contraints de se faire vacciner
donc en fait ça va être un vrai plus
dans la contrainte qu'autre chose mais
c'est un peu ce qui se passe depuis le
début tous les jeunes qui se sont fait
vacciner et moi je rencontre plein de
personnes qui se sont fait vacciner
parce que justement eh bien elle ne
pouvait plus aller au resto quand elle
le voulait comme elle voulait au cinéma
externe etc donc il n'y a pas si vous
voulez mon avis il n'ya pas que le jeu
me suis fait vacciner parce que je sais
que c'est la meilleure des choses non il
ya aussi beaucoup de personnes qui se
sont fait vacciner et ça va être la même
chose pour les soignants parce que sans
me faire vacciner et bien je ne peux
plus accéder à telle ou telle loisirs et
pour le coup là sans faire vacciner et
bien je ne peut plus toucher mon salaire
est ce que tu veux il faut la pression
que j'ai c'est qu'il faut peut-être pas
non plus surestimer 7 cette frange anti
vaccins non il faut pas en tout cas à
ménager tout le système pour eux vous
disiez d'auteur c'est pour personnes
âgées de pâtir d'une décision politique
non c'est pas au personnage et de pâtir
de la décision des non vaccinés de ne
pas se faire vacciner pour me remettre
les choses dans l'ordre et là pour le
coup c'est difficile à comprendre pour
les payer au public c'est qu'on est
passé en un an d'un spectaculaire
retournement les français se méfier du
vaccin ils ont tous j'ai cette nouveauté
avec leurs bras d'une certaine façon
puisqu'ils sont tous se vacciner les
leçons d un dash royal on a souvent été
très résistante à une opinion qui est
aujourd'hui très favorable y compris
pour la vaccination obligatoire et on le
dit souvent chaque samedi quand on quand
on donne le nombre de personnes qui sont
allés manifester et qu'on compare aux
nombreux français qui sont envahis c'est
exactement et donc et donc il ya eu il
ya eu ce spectaculaire cette
spectaculaire inversion de dents dans
l'opinion est aujourd'hui oui il reste
une frange très minoritaire après je
suis pas d'accord non plus quand on dit
qu'il ya la pédagogie n'a pas été fait
ça fait quand même plus de neuf mois
désormais qu'on parle de ce vaccin savez
on a commencé par dire j'aime on
arrivera sur l'axé n'est pas ce qu'on a
pas de dose tout le monde voulait y
aller enfin le débat il est quand même
très présents olivier né en 1900 t a
pris la plume dès le mois de mars pour
écrire à tous les soignants dire
attention il faut vous faire vacciner
parce que c'est en train de devenir la
première à des doses au comunale allez-y
si vous n'y allez pas on devra imaginer
autre chose en juin il a pris la parole
en disant c'est toujours pas suffisant
on est encore sur des taux en expliquant
pourquoi quels étaient les bienfaits de
vaccination donc aujourd'hui voilà on
est vraiment sur une phrase une fraction
la plus résistante
c'est la politique de la carotte et
bâton les états unis avaient choisi la
carotte vous souvenez fils aîné 10
filets des gros lots et
des mitraillettes ou des
ressorts là nous on a plutôt choisi le
bâton mais j'ai en tout cas on dit pas
que la pédagogie n'a pas été fait me
suis complètement d'accord avec vous
mais est ce que disait la présentant
comme un revirement surprenant à partir
du moment où le chef d'état a dit bah il
va falloir vous faire vacciner si non
vous ne pourrez pas accéder à telle ou
telle ailleurs c'est plutôt rassurant
sur l'efficacité la parole et je suis
sûr ça s'est fait tout ça je trouve
enfin quand j'écoutais les soigneurs la
samba sow évoqué plusieurs choses la
première c'est que attention il ya une
vraie détresse des soignants elle a été
mesurée à leurs créateurs n'occupe les
soignants vont pas bien et ça va
évidemment ajouter à toutes les carences
que nous avons la deuxième chose c'est
que non il n'est pas acceptable de
comparer la france est en dictature
nos dirigeants des nazis ou des
soignants des nazis ça n'est pas
acceptable j'engage ces gens allez faire
un tour en afghanistan à écouter le
silence mortifère de la corée du nord je
pourrais vous en citer quelques-uns
comme ça et puis la troisième chose
c'est qu'on à s'interroger sur notre
société et l'aco vite c'est aussi ça
c'est de se poser quelques questions sur
monde dans quelle envie et je suis
frappé mois passent cette société du
mois du mois du mois du mois du mois de
ma liberté individuelle et non on n'est
pas dans une société où il n'y a que de
la liberté individuelle la liberté
individuelle on a des jeunes il faut
leur dire s'arrête au seuil de la voce
pas le droit de brûler un feu rouge
c'est pas loin de vous crachez ma copine
la figure j'ai pas loin de vous écraser
en roulant à 200 km/heure et là encore
on pourrait en faire une litanie est
donc cette liberté individuelle ne vaut
que lorsqu'on respecte la liberté de
l'autre donc celle du groupe et c'est ce
qui permet de vivre en démocratie
et donc je n'entends pas assez cette
idée toute simple qui est que le vaccin
permet de protéger l'autre la
collectivité notre société que si là
c'est pas le chaos en europe c'est parce
qu'elle vaccin car ce serait le chaos
sans le vaccin la vague delta aurait
balayé l'europe tout sur plan sanitaire
sur plan économique sociétal sans le
vaccin c'est le chaos cette
extraordinaire et donc les
90% bientôt de français qui sont fait
vacciner merci ils sont sauvés la
société 1
alors justement tiens ça nous amène à
une idée qui a eu l'idée de l' oblique
l'obligation vaccinale pour tous et une
proposition de loi qui a été faite par
le groupe socialiste au sénat marion
vivre nous rejoint pour nous expliquer
précisément bonjour marion certain que
les socialistes du sénat les sénateurs
socialistes vont proposer alors cette
proposition de loi elle a été déposée en
cette rentrée mais le groupe ps au sénat
la défense en fait depuis le début des
débats sur le pass sanitaire c'était au
mois de juillet dès le départ plutôt
qu'un pass eux sont favorables à une
vaccination obligatoire pour tous seule
façon à leurs yeux d'atteindre
l'immunité collective et d'éradiquer
efficacement le virus une position
partagée par les députés ps mais en
juillet dernier l'amendement que
portaient les sénateurs socialistes a
été rejetée par le gouvernement mais
aussi par la majorette majorité
sénatoriale est droite mais alors on l'a
bien compris marions-les les sénateurs
socialistes il insiste alors il dépose
cette fois ci une proposition de loi
quelles sont leurs arguments et bien il
y en a plusieurs pour l'obligation
vaccinale sais je cite la manifestation
de la primauté de l'intérêt général sur
l'étang tête tentation individualiste
l'idée c'est de mettre tout le monde au
même niveau pour ne pas créer de
fracture entre les français comme on
peut le voir aujourd'hui avec
l'obligation vaccinale imposé aux
soignants l'autre point c'est de dire
que l'obligation vaccinale permet de
réduire les inégalités sociales et
territoriales d'accès aux vaccins et
enfin les sénateurs socialistes veulent
qu'un gouvernement arrête je cite la
mascarade pour eux le pass sanitaire
c'est tout simplement une obligation
vaccinale qui ne dit pas son nom et je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
sénatrice ps de paris marie pierre de la
gontrie
aujourd'hui il y a déjà un grand nombre
de vaccins qui sont obligatoires et il
s'agit d'ajouter ce vaccin là à la liste
des vaccins obligatoires au fond c'est
la position y compris du gouvernement et
de ce point de vue c'est juste c'est à
dire que la mise en place du pass
sanitaire des contraintes pour les
soignants et cetera abouti à la même
chose mais ne le dit pas nous sommes
persuadés depuis le début que modifié ou
de vous fait cette proposition que le
gouvernement sera obligé d'y venir à ce
principe mais est ce que c'est parce que
ce n'est de l'opposition je ne sais pas
peut-être on ne sait jamais oliveira qui
estiment ils dis très clairement je ne
peut pas contraindre la population à se
faire vacciner donc dans les faits
comment les sénateurs comptent ils s'y
prendre et bien des sénateurs
socialistes devraient fonctionner comme
avec le permis de conduire vous devez
l'avoir toujours sur vous pour circuler
c'est une obligation et en cas de
contrôle ou d'infraction il y aura des
sanctions la volonté des sénateurs c'est
de sortir d'une politique de sécurité
sanitaire et de passer à une politique
de santé publique clairement assumé
alors proposition de loi sera débattue
le 13 octobre prochain et la sénatrice
marie pierre de la gontrie convient
d'entendre est plutôt optimiste selon
elle les oppositions sont moins marquées
que cet été notamment au centre du
groupe union centriste était de la
majorité sénatoriale de droite merci
marion voilà vous aurez régulièrement
dans cette émission des chroniques
préparé par les journalistes de la
rédaction de public sénat pour faire un
zoom sur tresses actuelle est là pour le
coup sûr des éléments de deux débats
matthieu croissandeau est ce que est ce
qu'on peut il croire à ce parce que là
on est on est on est vraiment de la
politique avec cette proposition
évidemment socialistes mais aussi
peut-être dans le le le l'endroit où le
gouvernement et où emmanuel macron va
vouloir mettre le curseur puisque ça a
marché avec une incitation très forte on
l'a dit début juillet est ce qui peut
aller encore plus loin pour l'instant il
a toujours défendu l' inverse on a
toujours dit qu'il ne voulait pas rendre
ce vaccin obligatoire il est passé par
une porte détournée en revendant se
passe sanitaire obligatoire mais
souvenez-vous on a eu un excès de
précaution au début souvenez il fallait
remplir pourquoi le consentement pour
vacciner les personnes âgées dans les
ehpad c'était une trentaine de pages
d'un questionnaire extrêmement long on
est passé d'un excès de précaution pour
tenter de convaincre cette opinion qui
était réticente à l'a1 peut-être un
excès de bâton pour pour la pousser à se
faire vacciner
décrété l'obligation vaccinale c'est une
décision qui est lourde on est en
campagne présidentielle faut pas
l'oublier qui va à rebours de ce qu'il
avait dit donc à mon avis ils vont
plutôt essayer de pousser le pass
sanitaire jusqu'à ce que tout le monde
sont inclinés ce qui est arrivé premier
méfait pardon plutôt que de décréter
l'obligation vaccinale parce que
finalement le pass sanitaires il produit
son effet il est efficace vous vous
lavez vous voulu laver n'hésitez enfin
il vous pouvez en témoigner
quotidiennement dans les en place au
sein des structures de puits et des
services à domicile aussi depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant et bien
sûr oui on n'est pas dans un état de
non-droit donc les choses s'applique
comme il est prévu qu'elle s'applique et
de fait ça a un effet sur le
comportement de chacun de nos
concitoyens et beaucoup effectivement
vous enverra la ville a fait que la
vaccination plutôt que d'avoir à faire
un test tous les trois jours assure sur
les samis aussi et les familles lyon au
cours de la même manière et certainement
beaucoup beaucoup ont été décidées grâce
à ce à cela un des éléments d'ailleurs
sur lequel il faut que l'état avance
encore beaucoup parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des professionnels des
établissements il faut avoir en tête qu
aujourd'hui parmi les plus de 80 ans un
certain nombre ne sont pas vaccinés
notamment parce que la politique d'aller
vers n'est pas suffisamment engagé de la
part de l'état parce que certes les plus
de 80 ans gambade difficultés peuvent
prendre rendez-vous dans des centres de
vaccination comme tout français pour
autant les personnes âgées qui ne
peuvent pas sortir seul de chez elle
c'est à nous et c'est à la puissance du
denier public d'organiser le fait qu'ils
puissent être vaccinés or aujourd'hui on
voit que près de 20% et plus de 80 ans
ou encore non vaccinés à domicile
j'aurais revenir sur
ce que ce que je garderai disais tout à
l'heure sur les risques que les
soignants non vaccinés faisait prendre à
leur passion est ce que c'est vrai aussi
dans vos établissements
l'essentiel c'était déjà que les
personnes âgées qui sont extrêmement
vulnérables plus que la population
générale à ce virus soit elle-même
protéger il faut quand même bien avoir
en tête que dès lors qu'on est vaccinée
certes on évite de contaminer a priori
des gens en tout cas les comptes a mis
moins sûr lucas contamine je parle sous
le regard du professeur mais surtout si
on attrape le virus pour ce come back
soon n'empêche pas d'attraper un virus
si on la trappe on en fait des forme
atténuée est à ce point que les
hospitalisations sont bien moindres et
surtout les décès possibles sont bien
moins en train de dire que si un salarié
vacciner fait pas prendre beaucoup de
risques aux résidents la séance est de
comprendre ce qui entre les lignes
l'essentiel c'est déjà que les personnes
les plus vulnérables puissent être
protégés elle-même ensuite de vacciner
un environnement de professionnels de
famille d'intervenants etc c'est une
mesure complémentaire pour effectivement
prévenir tout risque de développement de
clusters et on voit bien que depuis cet
été par exemple j'ai quelques adhérents
qui m'ont signalé quelques infections au
co vide parmi des personnes âgées est ce
que ça vient des familles est ce que ça
vient des professionnels je pense que ce
sera très difficile à déterminer mais
quoi qu'il en soit ces personnes âgées
étant vacciner elles n'ont pas développé
de forme d'un don déjà c'est un élément
extrêmement important et ensuite ça
participe aussi de cet effort collectif
d'immunité là pour le coup collective
beaucoup plus large qu'uniquement est-ce
que je suis un soignant auprès de
personnes âgées je suis un français qui
participe de cette vaccination de
l'ensemble des français et de faire
monter l'immunité collective donc oui il
fallait d'abord effectivement protéger
les plus vulnérables
d'où l'insistance pour les personnes
âgées qui vivent à domicile protéger
ceux qui sont a priori le plus en
contact avec elle donc ces
professionnels et par ailleurs faire un
effort collectif pour aller vers une
immunité collective mais il nous reste
un peu moins de cinq minutes on
terminera sur l'inculture alesi si vous
voulez prendre la bêche bien demain je
veux souligner que le pass sanitaire
cela passe vaccinale on arrive on va
aller à 90% de vacciner c'est gagné
c'est que la plier et puis qui va
accepter de faire des tests pcr à 40
euros pour aller dîner dehors ce sera
leur argumentation que sap a été fait
pour plein de raisons qui me regarde pas
je ne suis pas médecin mais je les
imagine assez bien la deuxième chose
qu'il faut encore rappeler que c'est pas
le pass ou le vaccin qui crée des
inégalités celle virus parce que le
virus ça tue les plus pauvres ça tue les
gens qui sont isolées je vais prendre
l'exemple des ehpad y sont à mort que de
la colline ils sont morts qu'ils avaient
envoyé personne on meurt de pas voir son
fils sa fille et ses petits enfants le
pass sanitaire ça a permis canfin et un
jeune un fils une fille qui vient de
mettre une main sur l'ajout de cette
personne âgée c'est le pass and i ter
qui a permis enfin de sauver ces
personnes d'une autre façon et donc là
encore s'il faut retrouver le sens de la
collectivité de l'autre oui c'est vrai à
kemmel on a l'une des infos du week-end
c'est la mise en examen de l'ancien
ministre la santé agnès buzyn est-ce que
c'est pas plutôt ceux qui refusent le
passage du ter qui au delà des sanctions
prennent des risques juridiques qui
pourraient se retrouver dans les
tribunaux pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui alors quand vous dites ceux qui
refusaient pleut pas salutaire c'est à
dire qu'ils refusent la vaccination par
a
en réalité non je pense pas qu'ils aient
ce risque-là de mise en danger est ce
que ça sera pas pourquoi mais peut tout
simplement parce qu'en fait ils vont
être interdits d'exercer en revanche
quand moi j'entends ce qui se dit autour
et je reviens sur le fameux cabinet
dentaire dont je vous parlais parce que
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais
c'est assez révélateur quand j'entends
une associé d'un cabinet dentaire me
dire mais je ne pourrai plus exercer
parce que mes assistants donc la plus de
la moitié des assistantes ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner et mon associé ne veut
pas se faire vacciner mais si il
n'exerce plus je dois mettre la clé sous
la porte donc je vais continuer là
effectivement on va on peut se retrouver
devant les tribunaux puisque on peut
avoir une interdiction d'exercer et donc
c'est de la médecine légale mais c'est
voyez ce genre de situation là qui sont
certainement il y en avait trop elles
vont être minoritaire mais il va quand
même y en avoir et donc je
commence à les gérer moi c'est la
question que je que je me pose il n'y a
pas du tout depuis les faux pas et les
fausses faut passer oui tout à fait
celui qui va utiliser un faux-pas sait
contaminé je ne sais pas qui c'est de la
mise en danger d'autrui bien sûr et
c'est puni et bien entendu je fais quoi
ce qui vient d'être dit un soignant qui
continuerait à exercer quelle que soit
sa position sans être vaccinés ces
pratiques je voudrais terminer avec vous
toujours professeur dray sur l'inculture
pas ce que c'est on l'a évoqué
rapidement en parlant de pédagogie en
parlant des messages qui avait pu passer
mais vous dites qu'une des réseaux et
des explications c'est cette inculture
qui grandit dans notre société voyez
bien culture dans un plat niveau la
première c'est également une culture
scientifique
oui mais la parole scientifique elle a
été sérieusement fragilisée par la crise
que l'on on a essayé on a essayé encore
encore et encore de dire des choses je
crois qu'en fait plutôt que de la
culture scientifique c'est la défiance
qui avait qui pose problème et que la
défiance envers ou départ le politique
et la société puis le corps scientifique
pose problème on peut pas demander au
public de tout savoir de tout comprendre
qu'il ya un moment c'est comme une
consultation il faut qu'on fasse
confiance à son médecin qui va vous dire
ce qu'il faut faire si vous le faites
pas confiance aux médecins c'est serré
une chose bien d'autres à culture et la
culture de ce qu'est l'histoire il ya
une culture de ce qu'est la société
toutes ces références au nazisme
et se prendre pour jean moulin quand on
est seulement un idiot utile dans une
manifestation ça pose problème donc oui
il va falloir qu'on réfléchisse la façon
de pallier à cette inculture et je vais
me répéter encore une fois mais surtout
à cet oubli du sens de la collectivité
merci beaucoup merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat mathieu ou
rester avec moi évidemment jusqu'à la
fin de ce sens public jour une rubrique
laquelle vous aurez droit tous les jours
les électeurs ont la parole